I'm Steven manda Jones I'm a gameplay
designer at 2k Australia I'm Anthony
Burch I'm a writer gearbox and we're
gonna talk about Athena while you watch
gameplay of Athena and Borderlands
pre-sequel
looks like we're ready to go so Anthony
donut tell us a little bit about what
part of the story we're at yeah no yeah
we're on the moon this is Elpis is
Pandora's moon that's pandorean that
distances first time you can actually
see it from not being on the planet so
Helios to your left
Chris figure other left you [ __ ] okay
so that's the this Hyperion space
station that handsome jack has built
already building it in the pre-sequel
he's already built up by the time
Portland's two starts at the beginning
of the game you get kicked out by a
bunch of bad guys and they basically
take control of it to do some really bad
stuff to the good people living on Elpis
so right now in the story we're trying
to find the jamming signal that's
preventing us from getting back to
Helios and we're going to shut it down
and in order to do that we're gonna have
to kill some dark Sider scavengers to
ingratiate ourselves to a different
scavenger band to be able to get inside
of their camp and murder all those guys
this is a game about teaching people how
to be empathetic to scavengers on the
moon by shooting them multiple times
with the Y's again so these are new art
for the vending machines and they're the
best the guns and space thing is one my
favorite things that's ever happened
it's kind of cool it's really really
neat
so chris is currently holding a laser
gun Stephen tell me about the laser gun
so it lasers are a whole new category of
weapons we have in model and the
pre-sequel the one we've got here it's a
TD or laser weapon so it has the usual
TDR thing where when you reload it you
will throw it like that which explodes
on the enemies but lasers actually have
an additional effect here CATIA where
the thrown gun will actually zap guys as
it flies through the air so you get even
more sort of damage through that reload
mechanic we should show us that by
reloading the gun while he's not three
inches away from something there we go
nice and you'll also notice that sort of
the firing rate of this laser gun is
kind of like a rail gun and there's
multiple firing modes for lasers the
railgun is when the weapon has a
Hyperion barrel but if it has different
barrels you can have like your
traditional blast to type lasers or like
you ghostbusters beam and so on so the
laser category of weapon is actually
more like several whole categories
crammed into one because there's just
tons a different variety they're just
using his tactics there when he was 5
feet away from somebody to switch to his
sniper rifle because solely hey why not
it's cool yeah so now he's got a
legendary I cry a pistol out yet maybe
we'll use Oh Chris you big dumb idiot so
there's a jump pad but you didn't charge
it up with a shot to the box that's
attached to the jump pad you nincompoop
so he's overcharging the jump pad here
by shooting that box and now it won't
quite be as lame and it will actually
get him to where it wants to be so we're
going to go outside and do some 0.02
Logie gun fighting yeah and what we're
going to see here as well is we've got a
cryo pistol equipped and cryo is one of
our new elements in bottle ends the
pre-sequel so you can get different
weapons or grenades that have this
element on them and as you can see it
can freeze the enemies
when the status effect triggers and when
they're frozen if you hit them with a
melee attack or explosive damage you can
actually shatter them and deal all this
extra damage and they break into little
pieces and it's kind of Awesome
as Chris nicely demonstrated there and
then and then I exactly so you have your
cooldown back for your your capstone for
the server rage yeah on a gray J so if
we do a slam here jump up in there and
slam down see this feather there and
then the Nova goes off and you've got a
whole bunch of your Maelstrom stacks
which you can stay down the bottom now
the plating Taylor has a cool-down of
about fifteen was it four years
fifteen seconds on that one but it's
good to use as frequently as you can for
all the extra steps to get from through
good idea
and we can see the Lightning stump and
the lightning and fire sighs it's like a
marriage and he's faced up a family [ __ ]
yeah the cool thing about the slams is
if you jump off a big height like that
the damage it does is actually
exponentially increased to the further
you go so [ __ ] really I didn't even know
that yeah it's sort of not like heavily
communicated it's just like if you start
doing these big slams off roofs you'll
notice that you're almost killing guys
in a single slams that's awesome it's
cool if you get the opportunity to do it
Chris is currently being obliterated by
a capacitor sugar off which are big
creatures that you generally want to
fight in vehicles and they can spawn
smaller enemies and is rapists so it
looks like we're going to go and grab a
vehicle as you suggested so this is one
of our new ones here it's the moon buggy
it's got a couple of weapon variants
here looks like we're going to grab the
missile pod and hop into it so players
who have used the runner in bottle and
one and two will be pretty familiar with
this kind of vehicle although it handles
a little bit different obviously because
we're on the moon now but yeah as we can
see it's got some cool new guns got the
missile pod there which fires a big
volley of homing missiles which will
sort of home in on whatever target is
under your reticle
and this is a two-person vehicle so if
you've got got a friend they can hop
into the back and man the guns for you
so now we're going to have a look at one
of our other new vehicles called the
Stingray which just going to load one up
here so I got a couple of weapon options
again so we're going to grab the crow
rocket stingray go souls and our skins
also cheating because I can actually
quite supposed to have it this early on
in the game we're just showing it to you
just to show it to you because it's fun
yeah it's kind of cool so as you can see
it's a it's like a hover bike here so
hovering above the ground and cruise
around it has instead of an afterburner
as you can see here it actually has a
vertical boost that you can use to jump
across things or up onto higher higher
levels Instagram Chris Chris has a cramp
Chris you're not hitting a sick ramp
that one right there mess it up three
two one sick ramp you did it
America was counting on you to shed it
the other cool thing you can do is when
you're up in the air if you hit what is
normally the handbrake button you can
slam back down to the ground and pancake
enemies hey there we go pancake foods on
these dead that's the cryo rocket weapon
not so good a place needs a little bit
of distance to get a timing working and
the other thing you'll notice with this
is it's obviously a single person
vehicle which is the first time water
Lance has had just a one passenger
vehicle normally what am I for one of my
three friends going to do on in one of
those well we've fortunately thought of
that and you can actually grab for
stingrays in a single game so all your
friends can have one each that's that's
unprecedented yep it's it's kind of cool
it's like a swarm of angry over B by
don't believe it yeah.that cry rocket
sure seems to immobilize enemies from a
distance yeah look at meteor make a wish
what's your wish Steven uh for that loot
fair enough
well done that's a bottle and a good
answer what else would be appropriate to
say world peace [ __ ] selfish they
don't think that's in character ah nice
moon skybox cool so we'll jump into
Athena's skill trees here so first up
we've got her action skill which is
called kinetic aspis basically it's a
famous personal shield and when she
activates it she pulls up her shield and
she can prevent all incoming damage from
a frontal direction and it's not only
that the shield will store that incoming
damage and she can then throw it out
into her enemies and deal double that
damage back to them that sounds
incredible tell me more about the
individual skill trees yeah sure so
first up we've got the phalanx tree
which is heavily focused on a per action
skill the aspis and buffing that up and
giving it additional effects for example
she can change it so that it will absorb
incoming elemental damage types with the
prismatic age of skill here so if it's
damaged by fire damage or shock damage
it will then deal that type back when
she throws it out which is really cool
that's electrifying Steven
there's also some really good co-op
buffs in this skill tree so if you're
playing with friends you've got nice
ways to sort of protect your friends
heal them pull them out of fight for
your life or draw aggro from the enemies
back on to Athena
so if you're playing like with a partner
or in a group this is a really good
skill tree for that the capstone skill
of this one is also really cool it's
called wrath of the goddess here it
basically allows the aspis to jump to
additional enemies when she throws it so
like if you filled it right up with a
ton of energy you can wipe out a whole
room of dudes with that one is super
cool so that tree was about playing with
friends what if I am alone in life well
that's the skill tree will still work
for you if you're alone in life that's
amazing
but moving on we've got the zyphus skill
tree here which is focused on a
close-combat weapon which is her sword
called zyphus it's an energy sword so
this skill tree is filled with lots of
melee buffs and high mobility things and
one of the key features of this skill
tree is with the Ren skill on the third
tier here she unlocks any status effect
for herself which is a bleed so her
melee attacks will cause enemies to
bleed over time and then moving on from
that she has skills like bloodlust on
the next tier which will help her
regenerate health as she makes people
bleed so as she spreads her bleeds
around the battlefield she gets stronger
and stronger and can keep going and as
we get down to a capstone skill here
which is called blood rush it basically
converts a malay attack into like a
dashing strike so that helps to get
those bleeds going on her targets and
the cool thing about this skill is if it
hits a target that isn't bleeding or
kill someone the cooldown it has is
immediately reset so you can sort of
chain it between a bunch of enemies and
just get them all bleeding at once which
is really cool
that was an interesting screen to go to
Chris tell us more about the final scale
tree
Stephen sure we've got the surrounding
storm skill tree here which is a
elemental skill tree it's mainly focused
on fire and shock damage it makes use of
nitrifying Stephen it's electrifying and
inflaming or not is what you meant to
say yeah that's a good one is this way
you're a writer it makes use of a
stacking mechanic using a maelstrom
which as you deal far in shock damage
you generate Maelstrom stacks which
increase your elemental damage output
and these stacks constantly decay over
time but that rate of decay increases as
you build up more so basically you get
these big spikes of power as you
generate your stacks you have a lot of
other skills such as smite which add
extra fire and shock attacks into your
arsenal this one is cool because when
you're airborne you can hit enemies with
this fire and shock damage from above
and since we've got low gravity like
it's really easy to trigger that off
because you can easily spend a lot of
time airborne um susses rage is a pretty
cool one as well it's a modification to
the aspis so when she throws it out it
spawns a fire lightning storm at the
target location dealing like constant
damage to anyone it hits and the cool
thing about that is it'll generate you a
ton of Maelstrom stacks as well so it
sort of snowballs you until this extra
damage if you are the cool skills here
as well like a capstone here hades
chuckles it modifies her slam attack so
that any enemies damaged by actually
tethers herself to them with like a
lightning tether and if she keeps that
tether without breaking it until the end
of the duration any tethered enemies
release a fire nova which puts more
people generates more Maelstrom stacks
achieving its Cronus Maelstrom stacks on
top of that so you really want to make
use of your slam and hit as many people
as you can and really get a big spike in
your mouse trim stacks so yeah this was
just a little bit of Borderlands the
pre-sequel with Anthony Burch I'm Steeve
Amanda Jones and
kiss people directly on the mouth that
you love
I put you on ice
hi buddy won't you to it so I can snap
your smug Nick myself
you look like ya feel free to be killed
by any of my highly professional minions
[Music]